[Music]
illness is universal access to care is
not and realizing this lit a fire in my
soul no one should die because they live
too far from a doctor or clinic I wish
that you would help us recruit the
largest army of community health workers
the world has ever known
by creating the Community Health Academy
a global platform to Train connect and
empower
[Music]
they had a big idea to change the world
but they couldn't do it alone so my wish
but my wish I wish my my weave I know
I wish
[Music]
epidemic diseases like Ebola HIV Zika
emerged from remote rural communities
including the rainforests of western
Central Africa these are the hotspots of
disease through the hotspots of
infections they're the hotspots of death
that are located in the blind spots of
the global health system the idea that
disease anywhere can be a threat to
people everywhere is very real so how do
we stop this well it's to enable
community health workers to prevent
detect and respond to outbreaks at their
very source there are a billion people
who live in the world's most remote
communities and while we've made great
advances in medicine and in technology
our innovations are not reaching the
last mile they're not reaching these
remote communities we launched a
nonprofit called last mile health and
last mile Health's mission is to bring a
healthcare worker within reach of
everyone everywhere
[Music]
oh you a community health worker is
someone who lives in one of these
communities that's cut off several days
away from the nearest clinic and they
may not have had a chance to finish even
high school I just need two hormones
they're trained to perform medical
skills that can save lives
[Music]
their job is to go door-to-door to
provide health care when I was little
hot dogs and passion become a nurse I
love taking care of children
so the community came here to find
people I wanted to have initiative what
these community health workers like
Serena are doing is trying to bring the
kind of health care your family doctor
may provide but in places your family
doctor may never go when I wake up in
the morning
put my back on Mumbai the distances that
I walk is sometimes 2 hours 3 hours in
the Forex some areas on creeks the join
with the ocean so they even cross it you
find it so difficult
Kamiya burgers are trained to address
the health problems of their own
community in a country like Liberia
it could mean helping a mother get
treatment for her child suffering from
malaria
this is Varsity sorrows and this is easy
team so the only time you can get it is
really every time in Liberia the
children died more than the others
because we have some people in the
villages you don't sleep on a mosquito
net we already know community health
workers can help healthcare systems save
more lives their ability to do that is
strengthened when they're enabled with
modern technology now is she saying that
your child has improved and went to
school to date if community health
workers were equipped with smart phones
this would increase their ability to
prevent detect and respond to outbreaks
and epidemics it's time for technology
to help reinvent health care on a
game-changing scale we are building the
world's first education platform for
community health workers that allow them
to see the condition
there's instruction on the phone to help
the worker decide what treatment to give
but equipping 50,000 community health
workers with smartphones is an
extraordinary ambitious effort larger
than what our organization alone could
take on it required collaboration we
realized that working together with
others partners like living goods
throughout philia would help us truly
solve that problem and then we learned
about the audacious project a new
opportunity that Ted and a group of
visionary philanthropists had been
working on to fund some of the boldest
most audacious ideas in the world so
that's all very exciting because many
many more millions of children and
families are now gonna have a chance of
getting it and they're gonna get it from
their own neighbors they say help work
out for everyone everywhere every
community health workers become the very
people who can make a difference I love
ginger community dog meat I have love
and passion for the job so I will
continue to work for my people we could
by 2030 save 30 million lives by
training these workers to do 30 services
we as people are not defined by the
conditions we face no matter how
hopeless they seem were defined by how
we respond to them and our response has
to demand a health worker for everyone
everywhere
[Music]